madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre ministre mes chers collègues le
24 février dernier jour de l'invasion
j'avais à cette tribune utilisait les
termes de guerre culturelle
d'anti-europe je voudrais revenir sur ce
point pour commencer mon intervention
je représente les Français d'Europe
centrale au premier loge de ce conflit
mais je représente aussi le
franco-allemand le franco-allemand
profond
le franco-allemand ancien et en plein
renouveau le franco-allemand solide le
franco-allemand citoyen il y a bientôt
80 années des ennemis héréditaires quand
les ruines sont encore fumantes à
certains endroits
quant au sortir de l'horreur des villes
entières ont encore faim et froid
l'hiver
quand la région de La Sarre est
française et le sera encore 12 ans en
proie des tensions communautaires
parfois violentes quand le bas de
Würtenberg n'est pas l'Allemagne mais
zone d'occupation et bien c'est à ce
moment dans ces tensions que ces ennemis
héréditaires par un contre-pied génial
au déterministe au nationalismes
étriqués que ces ennemis héréditaires
font une communauté du charbon et de
l'acier et fondent un modèle unique de
réconciliation par le faire ensemble sur
les terres belligènes de notre cher
Europe
oui
oui nos territoires sont belligènes et
il le resteront comment serait-il
autrement sur un isme assez contraints
tant de nations de peuples de religion
de système administratif de langue
d'alphabet même temps de système de
valeurs de nostalgie contradictoires se
sont entrecroisés s'entrecroisent encore
temps de migration parfois lente parfois
rapide parfois récente parfois ancienne
parfois spontanée parfois contraintes
tant de migrations qui enchante qui ont
rendu chacun aussi différents mais aussi
légitime que son voisin voit que son
colocataire
deux modèles face à cette question posée
depuis des siècles à notre Europe un
modèle impérialiste rétrograde souvent
violent la domination de l'une des
nations ou alors un modèle coopératif
qui prône l'unité dans la diversité
tournée vers les défis communs et
supérieures à partir d'une gestion
humanisme humaniste des conflits
indispensables à la diversité européenne
où l'histoire est un des bas
scientifique et un outil de
rapprochement où l'avenir de la planète
est un outil est un sujet commun et
urgent
aujourd'hui les masques sont tombés
l'histoire devient une arme au service
de l'état-major de l'agresseur les
soldats ne sont plus des citoyens
avertis
la langue devient à nous case
quand l'impérialisme moscovite se
concentre sur sa propre survie alimente
sa nostalgie comment pourra-t-il
affronter les vrais défis du 21e siècle
la défense de la planète la lutte contre
les inégalités comment pourra-t-il
participer de près ou de loin à un
effort commun
on nous accuse souvent d'utiliser des
grands mots que le terme de valeur ne
veut rien dire face à l'hiver qui arrive
et aux vrais intérêts de nos concitoyens
cette guerre met du concret de
l'évidence du tangible sur cette
confrontation de modèles cette
confrontation de valeur non nos valeurs
ne sont pas une novembre pour cacher
l'anti-France une novlangue pour cacher
la guerre sociale
le modèle portait sans masque
aujourd'hui par le régime de Moscou
c'est l'assignation à résidence
permanente assignation à résidence dans
ta langue dans une langue dans une
narration historique et les dernières
parodies de référendum l'ont prouvé ces
assignés à résidence n'ont même plus
besoin d'être chez eux pour que
l'empereur leur impose son choix nous
sommes revenus au temps de Google ce ne
sont plus les âmes mortes que l'on fait
participer ce sont les amants fuis les
familles réfugiées et déplacées dont on
nous explique qu'elles ont bien voté
dans notre modèle à nous nous battons
pour émanciper nous nous battons contre
l'assignation à résidence l'Union
européenne n'est pas un arrangement
tranquille quand tout va bien ce n'est
pas une vieille idée avachi de fin de
bonquet électorale et cette guerre nous
le rappelle l'Union européenne c'est une
méthode permanente de règlement
humaniste des conflits inhérents voire
nécessaire à nos territoires européens
c'est une idée jeune parfois incomprise
c'est une organisation qui se trompe et
qui fait des fautes parfois oui c'est
vrai mais c'est une idée vitale
indispensable à notre diversité
européenne et qui aujourd'hui nécessite
de notre part de la vaillance dans les
agressions qu'elle subit dans l'escalade
de violence dans le tourbillon de bas
instinct qui la menace
non défendre cette ligne ce n'est pas
être vate en guerre c'est être lucide
sur ce qu'une paix durable exige de
vaillance ce n'est pas être va ton
guerre mais être Battois pour la paix
ce n'est pas notre guerre c'est notre
confrontation
alors quelles conséquences pour nos
concitoyens pour notre rôle de
parlementaire français
chers collègues gardons-nous d'abord de
l'arrogance nous avons besoin d'un
langage de vérité et non de certitudes
et de division ce n'est pas l'arrogance
qui permettra la lente construction
d'institutions démocratiques fiables
mais l'entraide la franchise est
toujours le respect
Poutine est en difficulté sur le plan
militaire il est encore efficace sur le
plan politique et il m'est à l'épreuve
notre constance notre constance à
défendre nos valeurs notre constance à
défendre notre modèle et notre avenir
[Applaudissements]
nous nous députés démocrates depuis le
1er jour nous sommes très clairs sur
notre position et nous n'avons jamais
tergiverser nous sommes pour le
renforcement des sanctions à l'encontre
du régime de Moscou
nous devons nous plus nous engager dans
la reconstruction de l'Ukraine qu'est-ce
que cela veut dire bien entendu du dur
des bâtiments bombardés souvent sans
raison tactique des maisons des hôpitaux
des écoles des routes des ponts des
infrastructures
cela veut dire aussi remettre en place
des administrations fragiles depuis
longtemps à cause de la bureaucratie
ancienne ou de la corruption cela veut
dire recréer des circuits de finances
publiques et collective oui nous devons
commencer à reconstruire participer
aujourd'hui de façon assumée à cette
reconstruction tout d'abord parce que
les Ukrainiens nous le demandent en plus
des moyens militaires et il nous demande
même plus que de la reconstruction dans
tous les contacts les nombreuses visités
rencontrent que j'ai pu effectuer mais
interlocuteurs Ukrainiens parlent plus
de modernisation que de simples
reconstructions ils assument la
fragilité de leur démocratie récente
leur dysfonctionnement leur division et
ils ne veulent pas reconstruire à
l'identique dans un brand grand
bricolage plus ou moins humanitaire ni
reprendre les mêmes processus
ils veulent que nous les aidions à
moderniser à transformer à rendre leur
pratique publique plus transparentes et
plus efficaces je l'ai entendu de
gouverneur de régions de responsables
d'associations de maire de directeurs
d'école et d'hôpitaux nous avons des
outils en France et en Union européenne
nous avons des outils pour lutter contre
la corruption et pour la libre et juste
entreprise contre l'endotructrices et
pour la citoyenneté éclairée contre
l'embrigadement et pour l'émancipation
dans les écoles nous n'allons pas aider
des gentils contre des méchants nous
allons développer et construire sur un
territoire de conflits anciens et
récents nous allons construire avec
vaillance le seul modèle qui garantira
si nous y arrivons que la fin de la
guerre d'aujourd'hui ne sera pas
l'origine de celle de demain
il y a au cœur de notre action un enjeu
critique aujourd'hui dramatique les
enfants du crâne sont l'avenir de
l'Ukraine nous devons aider le système
scolaire à rester simplement en vie
reliés garder les enfants Ukrainiens que
nous avons accueillis les ramener dès
que possible aider à les éduquer
multiplier les échanges scolaires comme
nous l'avions fait entre Français et
Allemands et nous devons réussir à faire
revenir de captivité ce que le régime
russe a kidnappé et déporté il n'y a pas
d'autres mots
ce ne sera pas le geste d'un grand frère
à un petit frère de nations dominante à
des soi-disant esclaves ou colonisés
mais la lente construction d'une
coopération oui lucrée l'Ukraine
apportera la communauté s'efforce celle
que l'on connaît son agriculture mais
aussi la décarbonation de l'énergie
auquel on pense moins ou la numérisation
de l'état civil qui est une réussite
chez eux
c'est notre manière de faire c'est notre
mode de coopération notre boussole
européenne dans le fracas du monde
planifiée structuré et faire ensemble
dès aujourd'hui pour vivre en paix
durable et souveraine demain les
ukrainiens et les Ukrainiens se battent
pour leur liberté et la nôtre nous
devons les soutenir nous devons avec
vaillance et courage prendre la main
aujourd'hui sur la reconstruction pour
notre souveraineté et la leur je vous
remercie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]